[Music]
clogged arteries
the way the world moves is contributing
to rapid climate change
how bad is it the united nations says
nearly 25 percent of emissions comes
from cars
buses and trucks plus oil factor
u.s oil growth already showing signs of
peaking and with geopolitical risks
uncertain oil volatility may be too much
to stomach
it all has us thinking of less oil
reliance and more self-reliance
and if necessity is the mother of
invention electric vehicles are the
answer to many of the world's woes
i think it's basically financially
insane to buy anything
except an electric car that is
upgradable to autonomy
regardless of what you think of tesla's
ceo elon musk he's been onto something
for more than a decade
and as other car makers scramble to
catch up and out do electric vehicles
are one of the most competitive and
innovative markets to be in
[Music]
welcome to evs on the brink of change
i'm alex steele
over the next hour we will explore the
world of electric vehicles
our evs ripe for the mass adoption both
promised and pursued
is the innovation and investment really
there and how do you get behind the
wheel
we'll look at subsidies infrastructure
and global governments
first up it's important to keep in mind
evs are
not necessarily new
as early as the 19th century many cars
on the road were already electric and
appearing in newspaper ads like this one
in pittsburgh
but in 1908 henry ford introduces the
gas-powered model t
and until 1927 ford would perfect the
assembly line and build some 15 million
model t
cars it won't be until the mid-60s when
we start seeing electric cars come back
mostly concept models like the henny
kilowatt in the late 90s the world gets
its glimpse of hybrids
among them the toyota prius which rolls
into america dealerships in 2000
three years later tesla forms and in
2008 the company debuts the roadster
sports car
it's followed by the model s model x
model 3 and more at the same time
asia proves to be a dominant player the
nissan leaf becomes the world's
best-selling eevee in 2010
and china becomes the world's biggest ev
market ever
its billionaire investors include jack
ma and warren buffett
it all brings us to today bloomberg new
energy finance one of the most
prospective sources on the subject says
china will top 3 million ev sales in
four years
the u.s 1 million more than 230 ev
models are estimated
to be on the road by 2021 so what
exactly is an ev
how does it work and what's in it here's
your primer
electric vehicles a car that runs on
batteries
they work in lots of different ways
here's one of them
take a tesla a 300 mile battery pack is
made up of 7
000 lithium ion batteries inside the
batteries
tiny ions of lithium move from an object
called the cathode to the
anode the battery is made up of nickel
cobalt lithium and aluminum
this generates a flow of electrons or
electricity
these batteries pack a serious punch
they have a large
charge and discharge rate so they
produce a lot of energy
and you can reuse them a lot to prevent
the batteries from overheating
an ev uses a cool liquid that flows
between the batteries
then an inverter takes this power and
changes it to an alternating current
think of it as a voltage that changes
from there it produces a rotating
magnetic field in the motor and voila
you have power the drivetrain
distributes that power to the wheels
so you can drive your car any
electricity that isn't used like if you
slam on your brakes
is sent back to the battery pack the 36
000
chevy bolt goes 238 miles on a charge
and the top tier tesla model s can go
315 miles
after that you gotta charge it about 30
minutes at a station and almost a full
day if you plug it into your home
the cool part is the battery sits low
and flat on the bottom of the car
think of it like a skateboard this lower
center of gravity helps balance your
driving
so does it all work well the us average
cost of gasoline is 2.55 cents a gallon
it's 121 for an electric e gallon you
save
50 percent now prices do vary and the
more miles you go the more expensive the
car can be and prices can range anywhere
from 30
000 to 180 000 but the hype is hot
the personalities are big cars are sleek
is it worth it now that we've seen how
evs work
who's actually driving them mary nichols
chair of the california's air resources
board
paints the picture the biggest problem
we have with electric vehicles is
nothing about the cars
or even about the charging the biggest
problem is that
people don't know that they're out there
you have to hit critical mass
so people actually see enough of them
governments from u.s to norway to
germany to china
have spent billions in subsidies to
convince drivers to
buy evs with all the you know goodies
that the government is giving them and
some of the states now sort of
providing some significant incentives
for them as well the consumers are still
not buying them
where they are buying them is china the
biggest market in the world
sales of ev cars buses and commercial
evs soared to 1.3 million by 2018
a huge increase in just a few years wan
gong
is considered china's father of electric
cars
the sale of new energy cars has
increased nearly 60
which is very fast growth if there was a
signal it tells us that we need new
energy cars
[Music]
the worries about evs are the same that
people battle in the 70s
reliability and cost if you buy a 30 000
electric vehicle it can take you five to
six years to get paid back for that
investment
cheaper better batteries and more
charging stations can help with that
and in the meantime car makers are
trapped they have to spend billions of
dollars to develop evs which aren't
profitable yet and are forced into
partnerships with rivals to try to
accelerate that profitability
whether they like it or not the business
part of you wouldn't do these things
but that's because the leadership part
of you requires that you do it you have
to invest in things that
are uncertain that before they're ready
because when they are ready you can't
catch up
and whoever finds the right formula
could win big
will they be at the forefront of another
revolution or will their eevee dreams
get crushed like they did
a hundred years ago
ford has made a commitment to be carb
neutral
by 2030 so we're actually leading our
industry
by asserting that the time is right for
the auto industry
to take this position the company
recently made waves with an ev version
of its iconic mustang the maquis
the design challenge was to take
what has been missing in electric
vehicles and create the passion that
follows with mustangs and marry those
together
ford's goal is to have 40 percent of all
its models bevs in 2020.
we think that by kind of middle of the
next decade it will be
50 of vehicles sold will be electrified
to some degree
we see a big market for of course hybrid
vehicles and that will be our
dominant technology into the future
still toyota hopes to sell 5.5 million
evs globally by 2030.
what is the next big thing for
forexlogging this is it it's uh
i think the electric car which is really
the best choice for many of our
customers
volkswagen just increased its budget for
evs by 36
to 60 billion euros for the next five
years with the goal of producing 80
models by 2025.
about 15 to 16 percent of our sales will
be coming from evs there is going to be
a revolution
there is going to be this new wave
coming and when you have that you want
to position yourselves at the front of
the line
and it's trying to take on the low end
of the market with a car priced under 33
000 alone is going to introduce 20
models
in five years he's the trent in
electrification he's here trending
in connectivity so what's coming next a
lot
a lot and fast evs have transformed a
lot
since the model t so where does it go
from here
[Music]
i think it's it's really too early to
pick you know potential winners and
losers in this
and so it really is a mess for the
automakers right now dave sargen is vice
president of global automotive at jd
power and spends his time researching
global autos
those who are first to market often
aren't the ones who are
successful in the long term i mean look
at tesla it's had a lot of wins recently
its model 3 was the best-selling ev in
the u.s last year leaving its other
models and the competition
in the dust the problem lies in
profitability
it seems like the more cars tesla sells
the more money it actually loses
revenue per unit now fell below 54 000
in the third quarter really putting
pressure on other car companies
we'll have very strong products coming
up and you know the penetration is
growing as well it takes a period of
time and people have different
assumptions
on how quickly that's going to grow but
we do think this is a market that grows
and we will take our rightful share of
that if you ask me
who's the biggest competitor to tesla we
don't think it is
toyota or general motors right now we
think it is
large tech firms that are worth a
trillion dollars or
worth more than all of my auto companies
combined these are the types of
companies that have the ability to track
talent and capital
and frankly to lose money if necessary
to take on someone like tesla
sounds perfect right people want the
cars car companies make them done
not so much here's the problem car
makers are going to spend at least 141
billion dollars in electrification
and right now most of the cars really
can't earn a profit u.s consulting firm
mckenzie estimates that an ev cost
twelve thousand dollars more to produce
than regular cars
so it's a vicious catch-22 to make money
car makers need more people to buy them
to buy more evs people need more choices
more choices means producing more cars
at a loss
companies also need input costs like
batteries to come down
analysts estimate this could take more
than five years in the meantime
companies are forced into partnerships
with rivals to try to accelerate
profitability
whether they like it or not
psa owner peugeot wants to have 80
percent of all its models be electric by
2023
and wants to join forces with thea to
tackle this pricey shift
this transformation for the industry is
going to be a challenge for many oems
it's going to be a kind of darwinian
period for for the industry
but hold on this is going to be bumpy
for the next few years
i think that the notion of any one
company going alone
into this new future is something that
you're probably not going to see a lot
of
ford and volkswagen recently joined
forces to develop electric and
self-driving cars
the business part of you wouldn't do
these things
but that's because the leadership part
of you requires that you do it
ford will build battery cars on vw's
platform and bw will invest 2.6 billion
dollars in ford's autonomous affiliate
argo ai
it just makes sense for even for two big
companies to share some of the efforts
which will make both companies faster
and more efficient
volkswagen and its chinese jv partner
are investing more than 4.4 billion
dollars in 2020 to rev up production
you also immediately have the market to
scale up and it'll allow that group of
companies to get faster to market with
affordable technology that now may
actually give them a little bit of a
competitive advantage
for a few years versus trying to do it
alone they have to make big investments
into a very uncertain future which
nobody really likes to do
and those evs that have come to market
haven't been able to knock tesla off its
throne
mercedes just put off its u.s debut by a
year
so to fight tepid demand original
equipment manufacturers or oems
need each other mckenzie says two of
them co-developing a dedicated ev
platform can reduce costs by 1500 to 2
000 per car now so far a lot of these
partnerships have been
with battery companies so car companies
like volkswagen bmw and volvo and tesla
are signing multi-billion dollar battery
deals as they scramble
to secure capacity gm is the latest
teaming up with south korea's lg
chem to build an ev battery plant in
ohio this battery plant is
a very important part to providing the
volume for
the electric vehicles will be producing
in the united states so it will be very
significant
we are bringing the best battery
technology
to the joint venture to create the
future together to share the vision
that mary better laid out all future
electric
car companies hope to reduce material
costs and find synergies to free up more
cash to invest in evs
some auto companies really have a high
level of urgency
and have kind of you know accepted that
they need to go all
in on this but they're going to require
some planning and some support from
regulatory bodies governments it's not
going to be easy unfortunately
volvo and geely are merging their engine
operations into a standalone company
volvo plans to roll out a new ev model
every year until 2025 to shrink its
carbon footprint and spending almost 50
billion dollars to do it
and it's the established car companies
that need the help
i think the biggest losers would be
companies that have to defend
a declining business model that is at
the margin
uh obsolete and or doesn't have the
backing
from the state or a national policy to
be able to absorb losses from flipping
the business model that might sound like
the average auto company and
it is and that's why experts think it's
big tech companies that will come out
as big winners you're in the business of
monetizing the utility
of the platform of the mobility device
that's increasingly going to be an
electronic
device not a mechanically engineered
powered by
an internal combustion engine it's a
electronic device powered by a battery
at the consumer electronics show in
vegas this year amazon intel qualcomm
and blackberry all made their pitch to
car companies
enticing them with data crunching
services like better chips and sensors
for driverless cars
we believe the real commercial
opportunity will be to add
autonomy to every car as a convenient
feature with the driver behind the wheel
tech can also help with mapping and
souped up navigation systems
intel says the market for such data will
be worth as much as three and a half
billion a year by 2030.
it's a computer on wheels it's a device
that can be monetized beyond its sale
as a mobility device and as a digital
device
last year the world bought more than 2
million evs in 2025
they'll buy 10 million and by 2040 56
million as they continue to gain market
share
but to do it the cars need to get
cheaper so these bars show what
percentage of the cars price comes from
its battery and right now
that's a 35 now this white line here
shows the cost of a regular internal
combustion engine and shows that evs are
going to cost more until 2024
then there's parody evs get a lot
cheaper and the cost of batteries come
down
now keep in mind a lot goes into this if
you had a home charger it delays this
price parity by one to three years
if you're in china evs will stay more
expensive for longer because car prices
are lower than in other countries
and let's take the us you get a 2500 to
7500 tax credit depending on the size of
the battery when you buy an ev
and it's available for the first 200 000
cars sold by a manufacturer
and states can offer even more help take
california
it's ev sales have surged since 2017 and
if it were a country
it'll be the second biggest buyer of evs
in the world
[Music]
we won't make it to healthy air without
a much greater penetration of electric
vehicles so
we had to be out there beating the drums
and then we had to put our money where
our mouth was
by coming up with incentives mary
nichols is the chairwoman of california
air resources board and is a big driver
of the state's clean air rules
it's not just the monetary incentive
it's the fact that you can get a sticker
to go in the carpool lane
even if you're only a solo driver that
is actually turned out to be the biggest
incentive that is the thing that has
drawn more
middle class commuters into making that
choice to go electric
now senate minority leader chuck schumer
is floating a 454 billion dollar plan
where customers will be given a
substantial cash voucher to trade in
older gasoline cars for evs or other
hybrid options
when the ev tax credit was originated
it was literally the authors went to the
senate floor and said
this is a bill to help us get off of
foreign oil
we want to help spur the production of
electric vehicles
tom pyle is president of the american
energy alliance and is ardently
anti-subsidies and a huge proponent of a
free market
system one of the authors former senator
hatch said
we specifically are limiting this to 200
000 vehicles per company
because we don't want to be one of those
things where everyone just
depends on the subsidy we want to spur
the technology
and then let the industry go from there
many credits can wind up in the hands of
the wrong people the u.s treasury
department watchdog tigta
found 70 million dollars was given to
car buyers filing improper claims
how this happens is still unclear but
the report did say the irs
didn't have a good way to prevent it
senator bill cassidy also criticized
these credits saying
you have to realize that electric car
vehicles are being bought by the
well-off and being subsidized by those
who are less well-off
bottom line is the government shouldn't
be
getting into the business of sort of
picking winners and losers
amongst industries or technologies and
even with these subsidies
sales of evs only reached 2 percent of
total car sales in the past 10 years
and then there's europe from norway to
the uk
sales have jumped in the first half of
2019 evs make up 42 percent of new car
sales in norway
the country has a target of zero
emission cars making up all new sales
by 2025. there's this big push on
reducing co2 emissions from the european
commission and
the targets that they have set for 2030
for the auto sector you can't really
meet them without a lot of evs in the
mix you can't really get there with
internal combustion engine improvements
alone
europe norway although those countries
are very different in terms of how that
they're structured
norway is one of the leaders it exempts
ev purchases from a 25
value-added tax and puts higher taxes on
gasoline cars
forcing consumers into the ev option
their citizens have a much higher
level of tolerance for taxation and sort
of
government getting involved in their
lives it's a very different market there
too
it's a much smaller country they're more
concentrated in
in you know urban areas germany has now
overtaken norway and ev sales
just barely the country also earmarked
54 billion euros to fight climate change
and part of that is subsidies for evs
you can get a bonus now of as much as 6
600
and the auto industry covers half the
cost this should provide support
for as much as 700 000 evs you're
starting to see some of the bigger car
markets so places like
germany the uk and france you're still
only a few percent of sales there but
it's rising quickly
china started subsidizing evs for the
government in public fleets back in 2009
and for regular car buyers in 2013.
now the subsidies range from 5 000 to 8
500 depending on the range of the car
and were paid directly to the
manufacturers the goal
is for new energy vehicles so evs
hybrids and fuel cell cars
to hit 7 million units by 2025.
[Music]
the chinese government sees promoting
electric vehicles as a major strategic
priority and i think there are four
reasons
one of them is cutting local air
pollution and that's a crisis
in many chinese cities today david
sandola from columbia university is an
expert in subsidies
and is optimistic a second is fighting
global warming and the chinese
government has stated its commitment to
that
a third is reducing their oil imports
china today is 70
dependent on oil imports and then a
fourth is positioning their industry
for the global market in electric
vehicles they see electric vehicles as
an industry of the future
china spent more than 30 billion dollars
subsidizing evs and it's paid off
sales have soared since 2018. those
types of subsidies make a big difference
however this could all change china now
faces a 50
cut in national subsidies and a complete
phase out by 2021
and it's had an impact sales of evs are
now down six straight months since the
subsidy cut started
in july the subsidy going away in the
next 12 to 24 months or being
dramatically reduced will have a impact
on
the players that's coming to market
brian goo is a former wall street banker
and is now president of x-pang
an ev company in china these players
will not have the window like what we
had
to access market with the support of the
government so for them to have a product
a year from today they will be faced
with a lot of competition
and very small government support china
is backed down somewhat saying subsidies
won't be cut this july
at the same time china is funneling more
money into expanding the number of
charging stations
china has eight public chargers for
every one in the u.s the darker the pink
the more charging stations an area has
and the us really only has california in
the long run it actually will be good
for the whole sector
because subsidy itself is actually
benefiting the low end players
and actually getting rid of the sexy or
reducing subsidy
forces consumer to focus on the product
differentiation
and quality and value proposition which
is something that we are emphasizing as
well
it's a similar story in the u.s once a
car company reaches 200 000 in sales the
subsidies disappear
now both gm and tesla have hit that mark
and they saw their quarterly sales fall
as a result
at the end of the day it's the
manufacturers who are
getting the subsidy because even though
it doesn't go to them directly
this is the only way they're going to be
able to sell these cars so in the early
stages
you have to have the subsidies when you
get the subsidies out of the system
you're going to see a desire for these
car companies to race to get
a better product out on the market
that's more affordable there is a push
to extend the 7
000 credit through 2024 and only limited
after a car company sells 600 000
vehicles which would give companies like
tesla
a lot more runway i think the united
states has got tremendous capacity to
lead the world in this area
elon musk is celebrating his first tesla
plan outside the u.s and shanghai and
tesla could now be a dominant threat to
one of the most competitive ev markets
in the world
[Music]
evs make up five percent of new car
sales in china and the government wants
to get that number to 25
fighting pollution is a priority for
president xi jinping
harm we inflict on nature will
eventually return to haunt us
this is a reality we have to face
hundreds of thousands have died in china
from respiratory infections
lung cancer and stroke all attributable
to air pollution china is the market
that's leading the
commercialization of electric vehicle
technology and views its future
as an electric future and where there's
the will there's the money
there are hundreds of car companies in
china backed by some of the biggest
billionaires in the world
that all want to take on the number one
spot like xpang and its evg3
a tesla competitor at half the price if
you are one of the top companies
you have no trouble attracting capital
jack ma's alibaba put its money with
wall street veteran brian goo
who leads xpang the ev hopeful raised
more than 900 million dollars in 2019
and another 400 million from companies
including xiaomi
most players actually are fading away
because this business actually requires
a lot of
resources a lot of commitment and i
don't think most
players will be able to attract the
resources and talents
and have the ability of building
organizations to meet that requirement
expanding sold over 11 000 cars so far
in 2019.
the china auto industry is a relatively
recent
creation this is a it is the world's
largest auto market but it wasn't that
just
15 years ago when i moved to china 2004
it was one-tenth the size of what it is
now
and it's all because of this man wang
gong who became chief scientist of the
eevee project in 2011.
coping with climate change is our common
responsibility we must recognize that we
are one of the world's largest emitters
of carbon dioxide
which is why we have been working hard
in this area for more than five years
china is seeking to create a new
propulsion backbone
because it's in the domestic advantage
to do so to be the world's
base and consumption base for electric
propulsion
gives china an inside lane to the future
of mobility
china is considering a target of 60 of
all automobiles sold in the country to
run on electric motors by 2035
and the nation is building at least 20
ev towns for car makers in other
industries
doesn't waste some time we have a
responsibility to reduce emissions we
have a responsibility to contribute to
ecological civilization
a responsibility that might not see all
chinese eevee companies survive
baic blue park new energy technology
china's biggest maker of pure electric
cars
forecasts a 2019 loss in his earnings
update
warren buffett's back byd in october
reported an 89 percent decline in third
quarter earnings and one profit could
fall as much as 43 percent in 2019
the companies that compete here have
relatively short histories
they're more willing to embrace a new
technology solution because it's a more
level playing field there's less
history to have to overcome to catch up
with the incumbents
and then there's neo backed by pony ma
china's second richest person
and his company 10 cent they led a one
billion dollar investment round in 2017
the company now faces losses of almost
six billion dollars over the last five
years
to say we'll say that you can't ask a
four or five year old toddler to make
money
i think it's quite difficult cost
overruns weak sales and a recall for
about a quarter of its cars hurt neo
forcing it to cut 20 percent of its
workforce
if you look at tesla it has been
established for 16 years
neo has only been established for over
four years i'm sure that we don't need
over a decade to make profit
the company shells out 1.27 million u.n
for each car that sells for barely a
third of that
and it also recently launched more
promotions like zero percent interest
rates for three years and guaranteed
subsidies for cars registered before
february and they're all
trying to compete with tesla the top 10
selling evs in china are locally branded
tesla's not in that list we intend to
make continue making a significant
investment and increasing the investment
in china and tesla isn't the only
foreign company that wants in
battery technology already is deployed
at scale in china
you can expect all the ev subsystem
components to be localized in china
so that gives china a supply chain
advantage when it comes to supplying
not only the components for production
in china but also components for
production of evs anywhere in the world
audi plans to start selling nine new
energy vehicle models in china during
the next two years
bmw will build the ix3 crossover in
china next year and is working with a
chinese partner to electrify its mini
model
and daimler is partnering to grow it's
not just about
capturing the chinese market we also
want to be
doing r d there our r d team is growing
we're looking at a supply network which
is uh
very interesting daimler and chinese
company gili recently established their
joint venture with 780 million dollars
in capital to partner in self-driving
cars
we will develop smart together and you
will see the first
fruits of that cooperation with new
generation of products coming in 2022 so
we are quite excited about that
the world owes elon musk and his company
a debt of gratitude that it has
demonstrated that there is a market for
electric vehicles
how quickly the world moves to evs
depends on money
right now it can take five to six years
for you to get paid back for buying a
thirty thousand dollar ev in the us
to get that cost down battery prices
have to fall
the good news battery prices are down
eighty nine percent since twenty ten
the bad news is that might not last
here's the problem
lithium producers went full speed ahead
on production betting on rising demand
from evs
that demand did not materialize as fast
as the industry thought
creating too much lithium voila lower
prices
about 70 of the world's lithium is in
south america
and in the hands of just a few companies
and you find it in two ways
traditional mining or in brine where you
pump large amounts of
water and churn up salty mud this brine
is then left in large pools to evaporate
before processing
it can take three to five years for a
new mine to be up and running so
investment needs to happen in the next
year and a half to meet demand
we estimate that out of the total demand
by 2025
around 80 will be electric cars
which is a very significant bloomberg
nef thinks the lithium battery market
could be a 116 billion
market in 10 years but for that to
happen prices have to fall
in 2019 an average battery pack was 156
dollars per kilowatt hour
and by 2030 it could be 63 dollars the
cheaper the battery the cheaper the car
the faster the adoption rate another
issue with banking on commodities like
lithium
cobalt and nickel is that they might not
be as clean or as
green as you think
the 20th century was the age of the
internal combustion engine
the 21st century will belong to the
battery
by 2040 the majority of cars sold around
the world will be powered by batteries
they'll emit far fewer pollutants than
gas guzzlers
but the elements used in batteries have
their own challenges
lithium is a water guzzler if lithium
prices stay
low it may not be worth the cost to mine
the industry would likely opt for the
more environmentally riskier method of
pumping salt water underground to
extract it
and nickel is used in lithium-ion
battery cathodes
it boosts energy density to let electric
vehicles travel faster and farther
but it's not clear whether miners in
indonesia can even keep a steady stream
of knuckle coming
and cobalt presents an ethics problem
it helps keep the battery cool during
charging and discharging
but they're terrible conditions for
miners in congo
the world's top producer some of the
workers that reporters have found there
are as young
as four years old cleaner car might not
be made more cleanly
another big problem sometimes
lithium-ion batteries can catch on fire
lithium ion can overheat and release an
oxygen which causes a fire
now some of these fires can be traced to
manufacturing issues in the battery
cells or
installation issues or even over
charging
one possible solution is changing the
fluid within the battery
typically a liquid electric moves ions
around to charge or discharge a battery
another option is solid-state batteries
which removes this liquid and uses
ceramic
glass or another solid material
solid-state batteries could reduce the
flammable risks and allow for thinner
and smaller packs that can fit right
under the car seat
the energy density in our solid state
battery is over twice of what we have
today which means
the space we have the same energy let's
say 100 kilowatt hour
we would take only half the space and
about half the weight
and then finally with our battery it's a
lot lower cost
right now we estimate that depending on
who you would quote it could be about
half the price
goldman says it could take five to ten
years for solid state batteries to
become a mass market
if you get solid-state batteries you can
put them all over the place you can even
integrate them into the structure of the
vehicle
so there's a whole new set of
opportunities as we move to solid-state
batteries
the third problem is charging stations
there aren't a lot of them and those
that are there aren't fast enough
bloomberg nef says by the end of 2018
there are more than 630
000 public charging stations around the
world and china had 460
000 of them only a quarter of public
charges that do exist
rank as fast while the majority are in
mid-range the goal
just one minute auto chiefs say
infrastructure is one of the biggest
headwinds they face
we have to kick off initiative to start
this
charging infrastructure i would love to
have more collaboration in europe
and all over the world with governments
to actually get more speed in the
infrastructure we will cover europe
with a fast charging network every 120
kilometers
we're also providing access to home
charging solutions and to
public charging networks we're getting a
little bit range phobic here and there
and it's always the reason behind it is
that you know the infrastructure is not
actually progressed
as fast as you thought it should be we
work really closely with the car
companies and say how many are you going
to be
deploying in the united states where are
you going to be deploying them and then
we go and make sure that we build there
so that people will buy them and feel
comfortable that the charging
infrastructure is there
evgo builds fast chargers of 50
kilowatts and partners with companies
like nissan and gm
we partner with lyft we partner with
with maven general motors short-term
leasing program that provides
evs to uber and lyft what we're seeing
is that that
is increasing dramatically and then not
just in california but in cities like
atlanta
and seattle it now has more than 1 000
chargers in 34 states and focuses on
retail
we have a partnership with albertson
safeway we have a partnership
with kroger we have a partnership with
whole foods why does that matter because
the use case for fast charging
exactly matches the dwell time of going
grocery shopping
you go to the grocery store you plug in
you get your chicken your salmon your
vegetables you come back out and your
car is charged
there are others tritium formed in 2001
by members of a solar car racing team
makes pumps that add more than 215 miles
of range in 10 minutes
teslas promise a 75-mile charge in five
minutes
[Music]
and lucid makes lightweight batteries
for racing cars with a top speed of 174
miles per hour
on one charge it has 20 percent more
battery density
and using that technology in consumer
cars could be a game changer for
charging
another option is going wireless for
over 10 years
we've been perfecting the wireless
charging
of electric vehicles alex cruzen leads a
team of mit scientists at witrity
to connect mobile electronic devices to
the electric grid
what it basically lets you do is move
power
at a distance efficiently from a coil
that would be
say on the floor of your garage just
think of a simple pad maybe the size of
a pizza box
a to a receiver that would be designed
in and built into the bottom of the car
[Music]
toyota's invested in the company and
licensed the technology and bmw used it
on their 530e i performance
so our view is we're going to make
charging completely transparent it's
something you just
never think about what really gets me
excited is
thinking about the future of mobility i
think we need to have
a industrial revolution 4.0 plus
for climate there is going to be a
revolution there is going to be this new
wave coming
we're looking at everything being
disrupted no driver
internal combustion engine giving way to
electrification flying cars potentially
it's a matter of i think a relatively
short period of time where there won't
even be a driver
we believe in five to ten years a car
will be differentiated with
how smart they are the vehicle will be
operated remotely by somebody
sitting behind a computer screen
welcome back to evs on the brink of
change i'm alex steele
there are varying predictions as to how
fast ev adoption will be
bloomberg nef is the most aggressive
with well over 500 million in sales
by 2040. essentially car dealers are
going to be bankrupt
mechanics are going to be bankrupt by
about 2025. it's not going to take that
long
tony siva is the author of clean
disruption of energy and transportation
a silicon valley entrepreneur and an
instructor at stanford university
and has made a career of studying
technology disruptions
any capital investment in the internal
combustion engine
value chain today is going to be wiped
out this is going to play out over
decades this is not going to happen next
year it's not going to happen the year
after
we are still at the very very early
stages of consumer adoption
the future's bright but there's still a
long way to go it's interesting that
people think that
disruption and technology innovation is
a zero-sum game
that you know there's one winner and one
one loser catherine mann has worked in
every economic job from the bush
administration's council of economic
advisors to the chief economist at the
oecd to the global chief economist at
city
of course it can drive economic growth
because there it is a new technology
so it's augmenting it's expanding
the sector it's expanding the use of
what an automobile is
it's not replacing all of the gas
powered vehicles
oil demand is going to drop by about 30
to 40 percent by 2030.
prices are going to drop to about 25
as soon as 2021. deepwater oil cannot
compete
and also the pipelines and the
refineries that serve those assets
are also going to be stranded for purely
economic basis
you can call it disrupting that sounds
bad but in fact it's enhanced technology
it's innovation it is responding to a
need
there's pretty profound impact if we do
see the degree of electrification
out to sort of 2040 oil demand in
passenger cars and oil demand in trucks
that peaks this side of 2030 that has
pretty profound implications for the
energy sector it doesn't mean that it
immediately drops to zero
today it's really hard to talk about evs
without talking about their sibling
avs autonomous vehicles in theory your
car would have autonomous
software that could be turned on updated
and used with a flick of a switch
avs are not exclusive to evs but when
car makers talk of the future
these two go hand in hand i think it's
basically financially insane to buy
anything except
an electric car that is that is
upgradable to autonomy
there are five levels let's call the
computer jane level one you and jane
steer and accelerate together
level two jane steers and accelerates
and decelerates but you still have to
stay awake
level three jane takes on the added
responsibility of monitoring your
driving environment you can check out
but be ready to control the car just in
case
level 4 high automation jane now drives
no backup driver needed and level five
full autonomy
jane does everything you take a nap
maybe you're not even in the car
it could eliminate 94 of crashes caused
by human error
city says level four on personal cars
could be deployed by the mid-2020s
you see these various consortia forming
around the world to try and jointly
develop these and defray some of the
costs of going into it so
some of it is around a story that
automakers want to tell about them being
innovative and them not being left
behind in the move to a more autonomous
shared connected future
tesla is by far the most ambitious
logging about 3 billion miles on
autopilot
but it's expensive companies have
already spent 14 billion
on external investments over the past
nine years with most automakers
targeting commercial launches around
2022.
the fact that you have both a technology
story you have a human behavior story
and you have a regulatory story means
this probably still does take some time
before it's really moving the needle on
global auto markets
the bad phantom braking not stopping for
a hazard
the good evasive steering emergency
braking and
driver alerts there's also kind of this
broader risk to society that
if you do really enable a level four
highly autonomous vehicles
do people just drive around a whole lot
more you're probably going to see more
regulations come down
to ensure that we don't create this
urban congestion
nightmare toyota has spent most on av
technologies about three billion dollars
on things from sensors mapping mobility
developers and services
now bmw daimler and volkswagen bought
here
technologies in 2015 for three billion
dollars the biggest av
deal ever and general motors is also
among the top five after buying crews in
2016. for 581 million
the av company now has a 19 billion
dollar valuation
volkswagen has a 2.6 billion dollar
investment in ford's autonomous company
argo ai which it bought for 1 billion in
2017
and is investing more than four times
that much through 2023
[Music]
we have to expand our sense of how is
wide sharing going to affect
the overall transportation marketplace
where the world of evs and avs intersect
is in ride sharing or the catch-all
phrase
mobility this can mean you using an uber
to get to work to a driverless car
delivering your lunch
in order to make the large shift to get
to like two percent easy adoption in the
u.s
to ten twenty percent it's going to be
the regulatory purview of a dense
community like a city
going after logistics taxis shared
mobility fleets
city thinks the u.s ride-hailing market
is already 150 billion dollars
and taxi avs could increase that number
by hundreds of billions
bloomberg nef expects shared mobility
services to rise to 19 percent of total
kilometers traveled by passenger cars by
2040.
there is a real crossover between
electrification and shared mobility so
just as an example you're already seeing
uh dd in china the chinese equivalent of
uber
already has a million electric vehicles
on its ride-hailing platform
there's about four million evs on the
road in china so a quarter of all evs
are
using this shared mobility platform
you'll see essentially robot taxis going
around and
just like you hail an uber or lyft today
or a dd
you're going to have a robot taxi neuro
a self-driving california startup backed
in part by softbank's vision fund
wants to create lightweight cars that
will deliver groceries and meals to your
home
it will also deliver food from kroger
and domino's in houston next year
citi says that any ev that doesn't have
an av platform will fall behind
and any av robo taxi that doesn't run on
an ev
will suffer an eventual cause
disadvantage and lack of consumer
enthusiasm
just no one can seem to agree on when
this is all happening
the combination of economics pressure
from cities and also sort of
corporate image concerns mean most
shared mobility applications are going
to go electric
it's just a question of the exact timing
but i think that comes pretty quickly
[Music]
the next step to mobility after evs and
avs
is flying cars we like to say that this
is closer than you think
we're aiming to actually launch our
aerial ride sharing network in 2023
uber and hyundai teamed up at ces to
develop a flying taxi
we have a network of now eight partners
hyundai is our eighth partner that is
joining
in working on this together the taxi
would be able to take off and land
vertically
accommodate four passengers and cruise
up to 200 miles per hour and
be fully electric with a range of 60
miles what we've
endeavored to do is really focus on this
being a partnership driven approach
the vehicle companies are the ones who
are really going to be investing to
bring these vehicles to market
and what we're able to do is leverage
the core technology that we have in a
way
that allows us to build the connectivity
behind the scenes and then bring those
vehicles into the platform
boeing airbus daimler toyota and porsche
are all investing in the sector
and city things sales of air taxis could
reach 5 billion a year by the end of
next decade
so what will the next decade hold
experts agree there will always be a
need for cars and trucks but for the
average person
the sedan will disappear so whether it's
a battery-powered ev
a fuel cell hydrogen car robo-taxi or
beyond
there is no doubt the vehicle that
transports us and how it transports us
is on the brink of change
i'm alex steele and thanks for joining
me this hour as we looked at electric
vehicles from all the angles
as for when your primary mode of
transportation will come on electrical
currents over gas
we'll have to see where governments
infrastructure incentives and innovation
drive us